watch the Skies over the White House and
the air traffic is constant
familiar flight doesn't trouble this
place or its president UFOs are a
different matter
as recovery continues of debris from
what he called a Chinese spy balloon Joe
Biden has ordered the shooting down of
three unidentifiable flying objects in
as many days we made sure to determine
whether or not they were manned
they were not
we did however assess that their
altitudes were considerably lower than
the Chinese high altitude balloon and
did pose a threat to civilian commercial
air traffic
the United States has been on a
heightened state of alert since the
discovery of the Chinese balloon and its
aerial destruction of South Carolina
it caused concern last week when it was
tracked above Montana 200 miles from a
missile base at Malmstrom
on Friday a fighter jet shot down an
unidentified object off northern Alaska
on Saturday Canadian Prime Minister
Justin Trudeau announced an unidentified
object had been shot down over Yukon in
Northwest Canada
in the latest incident an F-16 brought
down another unidentified object over
Lake Huron on the U.S Canada border they
have increased their
um what they're looking at and uh so you
know they're using technology that maybe
they're using more resources they're
putting more resources on the problem
and so they're finding more President
Biden was criticized over a delay in
shooting down the Chinese balloon he's
been quick to pull the trigger since
now he faces questions over a longer
term strategy how many objects are to be
shot down how often and how dangerous
will that get
and what about extraterrestrials
a U.S Air Force General said he wasn't
ruling them out the White House Press
Secretary weighed in there is no again
no indication of aliens or
extraterrestrial activity with these
recent takedowns
this is no laughing matter given the
uncertainty that surrounds the Skies
over North America with no immediate end
in sight
James Matthews Sky News in Washington